they're heading like this page was
stationary points and points inflection
we just as stationary points so this is
40 points of inflection so that previous
flowchart I just showed you what I
envision you're getting is a question
that says find the station locate the
stationary points and determine their
nature and that's the series of steps to
work with you and I hope you can see the
logic as to why like it's not just
random but you know sometimes i do a
table values and sometimes i've done
that's not random at all this good
reasons for this is what happens if the
question just says okay five points
inflection you don't need to determine
the nature of a point of inflection it's
just a point of inflection okay so
that's why this is rather less
complicated but there are still few
steps to it again so again from scratch
before i can do anything i have a
function what am I going to do okay so I
need to find the secondary to find the
second derivative I need to find the
first review so find you I'm the ex
that's your first time on the list off
of that your differentiate again to find
your second derivative okay and they're
just like before right what particular
places are we looking for with the
secondary what copies are not looking
for oh yes this girl is okay number one
I want to know where it zero but
secondly I want to know where their
discontent ooh it's just like this do
you see that in the commonality right
the critical points okay so i'm looking
for zeros or places where the second
derivative just doesn't exist at all so
again zeros or discontinuities not just
Canaries in the graph discontinuities in
the second derivative okay now if the
second derivative is never zero and
there are no discontinuities what does
that mean mean they can't possibly be
any points of inflection because they
all happen at here right so I'm going to
be a bit naughty enum because I've made
my box too small
I'm going to say there are no points of
inflection okay so that's great that's
it easy case however this is not usually
what happens I'll usually find either
yes i can solve for describe this for a
while and DX x equals 0 or i find a
place where the second derivative does
it exist so still gonna work out what's
going on so what I do what what makes a
point of inflection appoint inflection
what's the definition there's a change
in the side of the cake Appetit so that
means I've got our look to the left and
to the right I've got to do a table
values ok now after this table of values
one of two things will happen right
either see a change in the side and I
will not see a change in the soil what
happens if I don't see any change in
design if I don't see any then I go back
to hear there are no points of
inflection like I found places where the
first the second derivatives 0 if it
doesn't mean anything just like X to the
fourth alternatively i'll see ok concave
up con que domes or vice versa i will
see a change in concavity right so this
is no change and this is change right in
which case great i found a point
inflection and then at this point i
guess i want to take that x value pop it
back into the function and get a y-value
so I know exactly where the point of
inflection is is this always going to be
a horizontal ok so here right for this
this second scenario where I'm just
interested in points of inflection I
have completely skipped anything to do
with the first derivative I have no idea
what the first Ranger is equal to in
this scheme he across these steps so i
don't know if it's a horizontal point
however if the question was just finer
points of inflection it doesn't matter
whether it's horizontal or not it's a
point of inflection or it's not
appointed inflection the question of
whether it's on horizontal point of
inflection or not is really a question
that gets answered back here with
stationary points because you first
you'll find it's a stationary
one point then you'll find max or min or
horizontal okay so that's why this is
rather more complicated because there's
more more things ok any questions right
now um I mention this to a couple of you
briefly and probably but all of this
right it's a it doesn't tend to be a
means to an end what you're really going
to do is take that and add to everything
you already know about curr sketching
and then you can make a super accurate
graph and not be like oh I don't know it
turns I have no idea where it turns
right now you know now you can find out
for instance there's a graph that um
some of you guys ask me I try to be
equated now but it looked like this here
we go you are you found out there was
like a vertical asymptote ear vertical
asymptote here and it was a horizontal
asymptote at zero and you knew it would
do something like this and something
like this and then you said what was it
going to do in the middle right now what
you will find for the graphic I was
asked about is you get something like
this ok now the second derivative will
show you there's a point of inflection
right there I mean you can actually
guess it that without knowing the second
interview but the second derivative
tells you without a shadow of a doubt
it's like yeah yeah I can find that big
ok now it's worth learning I'm see this
thing here I know it's going to be a
rational function can anyone guess how I
know it's going to be rational rational
function means it's like you know it's
something written something just like
it's a ratio and it's a fractured the
way I know is because despite not see
you can see this question I have two
vertical asymptotes how do you get
vertical asymptotes when the water rises
when you have a denominator on and it
can't equal 0 so for instance I don't
know the denominator of this might be
say x squared minus 1 right do you see
when i factor out this I'll get like an
asymptote er had an asymptote here ok
now here's the thing if that's on my
denominator and then I have some stuff
up to the top
in 30 x okay that would that would do
what I wanted to when you differentiate
this here's the first derivative ok this
is you the spinners no dodging the
quotient rule here right so you say oh
ok it's going to be the you dash minus u
v dash right all over V squared ok
that's that now you can simplify that
but then when you go to a secondary do
you like oh my goodness this is going to
be a disaster because you have to do
this and then this again and your
denominator gets to be this awful thing
but it's okay it's alright you don't
need to fret because if you're going
through this process here for the second
derivative you don't need to know the
whole thing you just need to know when
it's zero or discontinuous right which
means you're only really interested in
the numerator that's where you get zeros
from right so even though you get some
terrible mess down the bottom x squared
minus 1 to the fall that's like a
polynomial degree a gross ok you don't
have to worry about him you just have to
worry about that you bring it up and
when it's zero and you will find a
single solution and if you wanted to you
could show as a positive collection
discontinuous looking at the denominator
so yes but as in that's easy you already
know what's happening at those
discontinuities because they the
discussion areas i get here a
discontinuities that i got from the
original function so i already know that
function does exist so don't worry about
it they can't be a point of inflection
there because there's no point so it's
ok maybe that's why I can even what I
kind of be all right